so we know that we live in an
enlightened age
when it comes to our understanding of
gender and by enlightened i mean
insane and confused we're told that men
are women and women are men and some
women are men and women
and some men are men and women and like
armadillos or whatever but the trans
agenda has run into a kind of a problem
which is sort of interesting
we're supposed to see men as women if
they call themselves women
but they aren't really women and other
men know that
and if other men are heterosexual then
they aren't going to be attracted to a
man just because he says he's a woman so
that
that presents a real problem you can't
blame heterosexual men for wanting
biological females
that's how they're oriented it's the
orientation it's their identity
you know that's the conundrum that the
gender warriors find themselves in
and uh they're always trying to find a
way out of it one way out of it is to
simply berate heterosexual men and
demand that they'd be attracted to
trans people so that's one thing you
could do find them attractive damn you
be attracted to these people another
strategy is what you find in this video
that we're gonna play for you right now
uh the person goes by the name don marie
this is a transgender person who
identifies as a woman
explaining uh just kind of laying out a
case for why
uh straight men should date
so-called trans women in fact the the
case being made here is that
is that that uh straight men are better
off dating
biological males who identify as women
let's give it a watch
today we're going to talk about the
reasons and the benefits
of dating a transgender woman and
why we are probably most likely
i don't want to be biased but why we're
probably
most likely a better candidate
of uh dating than like you know your
average
bish the first reason being we are
strong
strong individuals we've had to endure a
lot
you know within our life and we've been
through a lot
and it just makes us stronger people and
it makes us really sweet
you go through as much as a trans woman
who's been like
either kicked out of her home or she's
been
beat up by people by bullies and stuff
he's gonna be
a very very loving caring person because
she doesn't want anybody to feel
what she's been through you know so
she's going to be super sweet and she's
just going to be a loving person
so females aren't strong biological
women are not strong as what i'm getting
or sorry not female i believe the
scientific term i wrote it down here
being used here is um average damn
to describe biological women that's okay
okay
don't be insulted you can't be insulted
ladies
and if you are insulted you're not
allowed to say so because that's the
lesson remember that's if if you're
being insulted integrated by a trans
person
then if they're invading your privacy
even if they're going into your
locker room or your bathroom and you're
thinking gee i'd rather have privacy
uh you all you're allowed to do is smile
and say thank you so when you're being
insulted right now
that's all that is female empowerment
this right here this series of insults
and it continues and gets worse let's
keep watching
two for why you should date a trans
woman
instead i'm just kidding we are more
appreciative of the small things
we don't need you to like you know go by
us an expensive
lunch or you know
spend a hundred dollars on
something for me to be happy we just
want you to like hold our hands
in public we just want you to be happy
that you're with us
like you know little things like holding
your hand in public can make us super
happy
because you know there are people out
there that want to hide us so you know
we're
we're easy to please we don't we don't
have like super
unattainable like standards like we do
have standards
not gonna i don't think it's not like we
don't have standards but you know we
we are not just like stuck up and like
bougie and just
wanting the world from you we just
appreciate the small things
get it where i'm living okay so i'm
because i'm taking notes here and i'm so
i'm trying to you know just make sure
that i'm uh i'm listening and i'm being
a good student
so biological women are
weak materialistic stuck up bougie
that's what i'm gathering here
and i'm not saying that our friend don
marie
is saying that so so far this is just a
a parade of insults against
against women and uh there's not but
there's not so much of
a real case like we're not getting over
the
um the hump i was looking for a better
word to use there and i couldn't find it
so i just went with him
i we're not really getting over the hump
here of of this this difficulty
of how do you get around the fact that a
heterosexual male
is is actually actually once a female
that's the whole that's sort of like the
whole point really
um sexually if you're a heterosexual
male so we haven't gotten to that part
yet
maybe we will let's keep watching number
three for why it is
beneficial to date a transgender woman
is not all guys want to have kids
believe it or not right now i'm talking
to a guy who doesn't want to have kids
and that's where i actually got this
little pointer from um
you know we can't get pregnant which
means we don't have periods either
so a lot of guys don't want kids there's
so much pressure
to have a kid when there's a guy and a
female
you know in a relationship there's like
oh well now hurry up like we want you to
get married have some kids
you know not all guys want kids so you
know if you don't want kids
we're the perfect candidate for you like
at first i was like
you know maybe i'm i'm sad because i
want to have my own children too
but you know whatever like you know i'll
i'll keep my body nice and toned and fit
and you know
keep it stretch marks free you know i do
have stretch marks on the side of my
booty because it's growing
i just feel my brain cells committing
harry carey
they're they're committing ritualistic
suicide in protest
for subjecting them to this uh no
offense
so update the list biological women are
weak materialistic stuck up
bougie stretch mark riddled that's what
again that's that's the portrait rather
i should say the cartoon
of women that's being presented to us
here and not just here
the the entire the left's entire agenda
when it comes to gender
rests on this kind of thing by the way
trans women quote unquote can't get
pregnant
is that is that correct that's
true i mean that is finally some good
information we got we got one fact
in here and that's good that's that's
biologically correct information
but why do you think that is it's a man
baby oh see you've got let's think about
this for a second
all biological women um can get pregnant
barring old age or disease
right uh so in other words in principle
biological women can get pregnant on the
other hand
quote unquote trans women can never get
pregnant
ever under any circumstance
huh i mean it's it's almost like we have
two different categories of people here
and there's a there's a word for that
what's the word well you've got you've
got two
two potential categories um and so you
know on one hand you have people who can
get pregnant the other hand you have
people who can't get pregnant
and um what is it when you got two
different
categories oh binary yeah so it's almost
as if
we have a binary system here of uh
preg pre people who can get impregnated
and people who can impregnate
that's almost what it seems like i don't
know i gotta think more about this but
all right let's uh let's finish this up
number four would be
that we know a man's needs more than
your average
girl reason that being is because we've
been on the other side if you're
catching
my drift
i feel like number five is because trans
women
are more feminine and make more of an
effort
the reason that being is because we're
making up for what we
for what we lacked in our previous life
and you know we care about our
appearance
and we just want to look spruced up and
feminine
at all times guys love that guys
appreciate it
heard from a few guys that i've dated
like you know what like i really
appreciate trans women because
they actually take the time to get ready
and don't take advantage of being a
woman oh my god this hair is getting my
nerves right here
you guys actually like take the time and
effort to be feminine
and to be girly and you guys aren't
trying to like step all over our toes
all the time
okay well let's uh final update to the
list biological women
are weak materialistic stuck up bougie
fat stretch mark riddled lazy unfeminine
but other than that great and dawn i got
to tell you the people you're dating who
compliment you
on taking so long to get ready those are
called
gay men and a hint that they're gay
is that they're dating a biological male
so that's really kind of a dead giveaway
right there but if you need more um no
straight man
anywhere ever is eager for their their
wife or their girlfriend to take
more time to get ready that's just
doesn't it no straight men when their
woman
comes out of the bathroom after 98
minutes and you're late for your dinner
reservations
none of them are saying wow honey thank
you for putting so much effort into your
appearance
unless they're being sarcastic no
straight men are pounding on the door
saying hey babe just throw in some
sweatpants we gotta go
let's go that's a straight man it really
is amazing
the claim here is that biological men
identifying as women are not only
feminine
but more feminine they are better at
being women
than women are that's the message these
days
the message is if you're a woman uh as a
woman you can do anything
except be a woman because men are better
suited for that role
so what do we have here all told just to
summarize
we have a bunch of insulting
generalizations and stereotypes
along with a huge misunderstanding about
the nature of women and the desires of
of heterosexual men that's what we have
and that in fact is what what the whole
of left-wing gender theory is built upon
other than that great content
well thanks for watching the video guys
and remember if you uh i have to say
this to you
and beg you if you like the content then
stop being ungrateful and hit the like
button and hit subscribe
to show your appreciation damn it thanks
for watching